[Music]
hey guys
it's quinn here your friendly
neighborhood sci-fi guy
if you appreciate my content you can
help out tremendously by clicking the
like button
so that the youtube algorithm is willing
to circulate my content
thanks guys one of the first films ever
produced
centered around space travel 1902s a
trip to the moon was directed by george
mels
and can be loosely considered as the
first science fiction movie adaptation
ever
the short film was inspired by many
different works but much of it was
influenced by the work of jules verne
mainly his 1865 book from earth to the
moon
and the 1870 book around the moon which
was its sequel
the film itself follows a group of
scientists astronomers who travel from
planet earth to the moon
propelled through space by a cannon
attached to a capsule after exploring
the surface of the moon
they discover the inhabitants of the
moon
the film also takes from various
mythological sources
for instance the insect-like native
inhabitants of earth's moon
are called selenites after the greek
goddess of the moon
celine we could go into depth
deconstructing the short and highly
influential french film trip to the moon
but not in this video humankind didn't
get to the moon until 1969 of course
and please joe rogan fans save it just
save it
but by that time science fiction greats
like jules verne
robert heinlein frank herbert and isaac
asimov as well as countless others
had already been exploring outer space
in their books for years
asimov created the galactic empire as
it's known and thought of today
no question about it his foundation
series
is the most influential series of its
kind
and though highly controversial
heinlein's 1959 book starship
troopers set trends for the depiction of
futuristic military forces
and much of the science fiction that
followed arthur c
clarke's many works also helped
tremendously to popularize the idea of
space travel
in the 1950s and throughout the next
several decades
in 1950 clark actually wrote a short
book called
interplanetary flight which outlined the
basic concept of space travel to people
who weren't
necessarily familiar with the idea of
course this was based on their current
understanding
of astronautics at the time so not
exactly accurate today
arthur c clarke in particular made
several predictions about subjects
related to
but not directly tied to space travel
for example clark predicted the eventual
existence of telecommunications
satellites
the writers of the last couple of
hundred years especially the 40s
50s and 60s are the ones we remember
most when considering the history of
space travel and stories
but actually the idea of mankind
traveling through space
is much much older ancient in fact
there are hindu stories from the
ramayana which
is one of two major sanskrit epics
depicting flying machines capable of
destroying cities with advanced weapons
of mass destruction
and traveling into space these date back
to the 4th
and 5th century between 300 and 500 a.d
another example of an ancient text
depicting space travel that we have to
mention
is lucien of samosata's second century
novilla
or short novel depending on who you ask
true history
in authentic science fiction fashion
true history uses the setting of a
voyage through outer space
to make a statement on the use of
hyperbole in travel literature
the novella opens by explaining that the
story itself
is not in fact true and that everything
in it is in fact
a lie i write of matters which i neither
saw nor suffered
nor heard by reports from others which
are in no being nor possible
ever to have a beginning this depending
on how you look at it
might beg the question is that statement
itself a lie
but then that would be a paradox and it
gets messier from there but that's not
the point
and the novel we encounter alien life
forms worlds which operate by
alternative physical laws from our own
and interplanetary warfare for example
the protagonist of the novel
is the author lucian himself in the book
he witnesses the battle between the
people of the sun
and the people of the moon they fight
for the right to claim and colonize the
morning star
these were appointed to spin a web in
the air between the moon and the morning
star
which was done in an instant and made a
plain champagne upon which the foot
forces were planted
francois marie arue known mainly by his
pin name
voltaire wrote micromegas in 1752
in its space travel features prominently
it is also notable for suggesting that
people of other worlds
may in some ways have more advanced
technology than what is found on earth
the novel is named for one of its
characters that appears in the first of
seven chapters
micromegas is an inhabitant of one of
the planets orbiting the serious star
micromegas whose name literally means
small large
lives on a world more than 20 million
times the size of earth
and he himself is nearly 40 kilometers
tall
at age 450 micromagus is approaching the
end of his childhood micromegas
eventually travels from world to world
and a journey to develop his mind and
heart
he quickly spanned the milky way and i
am obliged to report that he never saw
throughout the stars it is made up of
the beautiful imperial sky that vikkar
der
durham
boast of having seen at the other end of
his telescope
the story describes his method of travel
as making use of the forces of repulsion
and attraction
which appears to be a clear reference to
the work of renowned scientist sir isaac
newton
it cannot be overstated the influence
that publications such as
amazing stories and weird tales had on
the sci-fi genre
these magazines often featured the work
of science fiction authors who are now
considered greats
in 1928 both magazines featured works
which essentially represented the birth
of the space opera
skylark of space by edward e smith which
i briefly mentioned in my video on
asimov's influence on the sci-fi genre
was published by amazing stories
originally in early 1928 and again
as a novel in 1946 though later versions
differ greatly from the original
publication
skylark of space depicted one of the
earliest depictions of interstellar
travel
it worked by combining a newly
discovered fictional element
known as element x with pure copper with
the final component being a field
generated by a particle accelerator
while we were unconscious miss vanaman
we had probably attained a velocity of
something like
7 billion 413 million miles per second
and that is the approximate speed at
which we are now traveling
we must be nearly six quadrillion miles
and that is a space of several hundred
light years
away from our solar system or more
plainly about six times as far away from
our earth as the north star is
we couldn't see our sun with a telescope
even if we knew which way to look for it
the same year weird tales published
edward hamilton's crashing sons
the third story in what would become
crashing sun's
interstellar patrol assembled from seven
stories in 1965
in a society that has colonized the
eight planets of our solar system
they had gone out to planet after planet
had conquered the strange atmospheres
and bacteria and gravitations until now
the races of man held sway over
all the sun's eight wheeling worlds and
it was from this earth
a thousand centuries before that there
had ventured out the first discoverers
crude little space boats whose faulty
gravity screens and uncertain controls
contrasted strangely
with the mighty leviathans that flashed
between the planets now
in the story a nearby star is swiftly
veering towards their sun
the destruction of their solar system
seems inevitable
and the current technology is not
capable of traveling to other stars in
an efficient manner
it would take them hundreds of years to
reach a new system
it is calculated by our astronomers that
in less than a year
our sun and this dying star will meet
head-on will crash together in a giant
flaming collision
and the result of that collision will be
the annihilation of our universe
for the planets of our system will
perish like flowers
in a furnace in that titanic holocaust
of crashing suns
in the story a team ends up journeying
beyond the solar system in a last-ditch
effort to save human society
now if we were to list every mention of
space travel
in every story since 300 a.d this video
will be hours long
what's important to take away from this
however is that humans have always
dreamed of traversing through the stars
essentially since forever humans
have the ability to look at the world
and see what it is
we reshape it to suit us we use the
resources around us to create new
technologies
that enrich our lives as long as there
has been a human species
we have been a species of innovators and
inventors
as we have conquered our globe one day
if we're lucky
we shall conquer others and hopefully we
as a species can learn to live in
balance with the environments that we
explore
rather than dominate them it only
requires a small leap of imagination
to look at what we have created on this
world and see the possibilities of what
we could make out there
among the stars
[Music]
you